bonsoir gilles eric séralini merci
d'être avec nous alors on est venu et le
maquereau prométhée en novembre 2010 est
que le glyphosate serait interdite nous
y sommes en 2020 et pourtant c'est
toujours pas le cas la faute à qui à
quoi
d'abord c'est la faute aux lobbys qui
sont extrêmement fort et qui ont des
pressions sur nos politiques aujourd'hui
qu'en français et allemand pour aider
bayer racheter monsanto
les premiers producteurs de glyphosate
au monde et il faut savoir deux choses
d'abord que les alternatives existent
puisque l'agriculture biologique sen
passe et qu'elle n'est pas aidé à la
mesure où l'on pourrait de manière à
développer des alternatives sur
glyphosate donc déjà il y à un faux
discours
la deuxième chose c'est que le meneur on
sait très peu que le glyphosate est en
fait mélangé à toute une série de
produits qui sont à base de pétrole
d'arsenic de métaux lourds et que ce
sont eux les vrais toxiques
les formules or nous déclarait il y a
donc fraudes et des associations
essayent de s'emparer de ce sujet pour
attaquer
non seulement le gouvernement mais les
producteurs de ces pesticides et
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs a mis sur le
marché
toute une série de produits sans
glyphosate mais pour le particulier et
ils contiennent du vinaigre de l'acide
acétique ou des extraits de géraniums
mais nous avons deux est dans une très
récente recherche s'est produit et ils
contiennent énormément de ce qu'on
appelle les hydrocarbures polycycliques
aromatiques
quand on trouvait aussi dans les gaz de
voitures ou qu'on trouve dans les
dérivés du pétrole et ils contiennent
énormément de métaux lourds dont
l'arsenic
c'est à dire que les procédés pour
fabriquer le niveau zac ou les
pesticides en général sont extrêmement
dommageable pour l'environnement
ce n'est donc pas seulement du
glyphosate donc il faut se passer mais
de l'ensemble des pesticides et les
méthodes existent déjà
il faut stimuler l'agriculture
écologique ou l'agro écologie ou
l'agriculture biologique alors on en
emmanuel macron avait déjà tempéré un
peu ça promet sa récente et qu'il allait
certainement pas y arriver en disant
qu'une interdiction du jour au lendemain
en gros tu re et notre agriculture est
ce que vous y croyez à cette version où
il a peut-être aussi peur de se mettre
les agriculteurs à dos qui constitue une
énorme économie en france évidemment
alors je ne sais pas si ça constitue une
énorme économie en fait ça nous coûte
très très cher puisque la politique
agricole commune qui subventionne cette
agriculture intensive et le premier
budget de l'europe qui est évidemment
alimenté par tous les pays dont la
france et l'allemagne
donc nous payons très cher cette
agriculture intensive et je pense que
manuel macro on savait dès le départ il
ne voulait pas sortir de l'agriculture
intensive
parce que les lobbystes justement sont
extrêmement forts cet argent qui vient
donc des impôts et bien sert à alimenter
la politique agricole commune qui va au
plus gros agriculteurs qui eux mêmes
avec cet argent rachète des pesticides
donc c'est un serpent vicieux qui se
mord la queue et qui nous coûtent très
cher au niveau de la santé au niveau de
la pollution au niveau 2 du climat parce
que l'agriculture selon le giec est bien
représenté au moins 30 % des causes et
dérèglement climatique
alors il ya quand même 7 millions
d'euros qui sont destinés à la recherche
pour trouver des alternatives aux qu'il
faut une leaf ozap qui vont être
investis 1 annonce du ministre de
l'agriculture
quoi c'est pour la communication ça on
imagine quand même que ça correspond à
une volonté réelle d'en changer de la
communication parce que c'est une toute
petite soeur et que les alternatives je
vous le dis existe déjà avec
l'agriculture biologique ou la loi
écologie
ou la permaculture il a été montré par
des rapports de la fao internationaux
que l'on pouvait nourrir 12 milliards
d'hommes avec l'agroécologie sur terre
ce n'est donc pas un problème en fait
l'agriculture intensive sert surtout à
nourrir les cochons les vaches et les
poulets qui sont un camp de
concentration
et c'est justement ce dont on veut plus
on veut de la bonne viande dans des
fermes ouvertes et c'est de système
qu'il faut changer
on n'a pas besoin de faire des
recherches technologiques pour continuer
à faire de l'agriculture intensive
on doit simplement changé méthodes et ça
on connaît toutes les manières de le
faire mais ça implique évidemment de
changer la politique agricole commune et
de moins à financer les grands groupes
dont emmanuel macron dépend lui-même
pour sa réélection
alors on nous promet quand même le
changement 2023 effectivement ça sera
après l'élection présidentielle vous y
croisez ce croyez-vous à cette
interdiction totale du dif aux attendes
2023 si ce sont les mêmes qui sont au
pouvoir en 2023 ils vont dire en 2025 et
ils vont continuer comme ça à nourrir la
bête
non je pense que réellement nous avons
non seulement toutes les alternatives
mais en plus
aujourd'hui vous savez nommant dernier
livre j'ai montré dans l'émotion toppers
que monsanto et bayer savait et nous en
avons les preuves c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que les avocats américains
ont gagné contre monsanto
il savait qu'il commercialisait des
produits toxiques notamment avec tous
ses produits ses poisons qui sont en
plus de befoza qui ne sont pas déclarés
dans la bouteille donc nous avons
aujourd'hui toutes les preuves
simplement c'est un système qui est au
pouvoir et qui continue à s'auto
alimenter merci beaucoup gilles eric
séralini professeur de biologie
moléculaire à l'université de caen
spécialiste des
pesticides merci d'avoir été avec nous
on dire avec sur rt france